economía/empresas 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela brandon daniela buena
noche bienvenida a brasil asumió la
presidencia rotativa del mercosur hola
raúl mire los presidentes del bloque
suramericano conformado por argentina
brasil paraguay y uruguay sostuvieron
una reunión virtual el jueves en la que
de nuevo quedaron al desnudo las
diferencias entre sus líderes como se
esperaba no se llegó a ningún acuerdo
sobre los dos temas centrales en
discusión que eran una rebaja de
aranceles comunes y una flexibilización
del mecanismo de negociaciones
comerciales externas a persistencia sin
fases la persistencia de puntos muertos
el uso de la regla del consenso como
instrumento de veto y castidad efectivo
y el apego a visiones arcaicas y
defensivas llegó soledad solo
consolidará en un sentimiento de
escepticismo y dudas sobre el potencial
real de mercosur o ciudades a tu tu me
acuso raúl mercosur está tan débil que
no ha podido sellar un acuerdo comercial
con la unión europea y uruguay ya dijo
que iba a buscar tratados por su cuenta
algo
tiene paraguay por supuesto no apoya así
es daniela continuamos con la cepal
porque al mundo su proyección de
crecimiento para américa latina la cepal
es la comisión económica para américa
latina y el caribe y cree que este año
la economía de la región va a crecer 5,2
por ciento y no 4.1 por ciento que
esperaba antes un buen repunte raúl
desde la profunda contracción del 6 8%
de 2020 a causa de la pandemia y en 2022
vemos un crecimiento de 2,9
es decir no recuperamos necesariamente
los niveles de antes de la pandemia en
todos los casos hay algunos países en
donde si se logra 19 de los 33 países de
la región no habrían recuperado el pib
de 2010 y más y si se cumplen estos
pronósticos la región crecería incluso
más de lo que prevé la comisión europea
para la zona euro aunque esto es un
efecto de rebote porque américa latina
cayó más que europa en el 2020 vamos a
europa porque hay revuelo en el gabinete
español por el consumo de carne es súper
interesante esta historia raúl mire todo
comenzó con una
al recomendación del ministro de consumo
que causó controversia en el gobierno de
coalición escuchemos lo que pensarían si
dijera que el consumo excesivo de carne
perjudica nuestra salud individual y
también nuestro planeta este
interrogante es el que ha motivado que
quiero hacer este vídeo estoy preocupado
estoy preocupado por la salud de
nuestros conciudadanos y estoy
preocupado por la salud de nuestro
planeta sin planeta no tenemos vida sin
planeta no tenemos salarios sin planeta
no tenemos economía y no lo estamos
cargando y una de las partes en la que
nos estamos cargando tenemos una
incidencia directa podemos cambiar
nuestra dieta y mejorar el estado del
planeta después de esto el ministro de
agricultura y los productores
reprendieron la campaña calificándola de
irresponsable en un país que primero es
el principal consumidor de carne de la
unión europea segundo es el el país en
el que el jamón es muy tradicional y
usted lo sabe raúl y tercero en el que
una quinta parte de las exportaciones
totales son carne hasta el jefe del
gobierno se pronunció desde lituania
lituania
esta polémica os lo diré en términos muy
personales a mí donde me pongan un
chuletón al punto
eso es imbatible
yo no tenía problema porque ya no como
carne de danielle eeuu de expresión su
preocupación por las políticas
energéticas de méxico bueno la
representante de comercio de eeuu
catherine talli estuvo de visita en ese
país un año después de que entrara en
vigencia el tratado teme que de estas
dos naciones con canadá allí expresó su
preocupación por las políticas
gubernamentales que favorecen a las
empresas estatales mexicanas el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
recordemos ha lanzado una campaña
nacionalista por ejemplo para impedir
que empresas extranjeras construyan
parques eólicos y solares para producir
energía danielle indicadores primero la
bolsa de nueva york cerró con pérdidas
en una jornada marcada por dudas sobre
la recuperación global después del cob y
19 la misma tendencia se observó en
américa latina sobre todo la bolsa de
buenos aires
para finalizar que nos trae como cifra
el día 800 de 75 millones de euros o mil
millones de dólares esta fue la multa
que impuso la comisión europea a los
fabricantes de automóviles alemanes
volkswagen y bmw w eso por confabularse
durante cinco años para evitar competir
entre sí en las tecnologías de reducción
de emisiones este es un cargo muy
conocido que se llama el diésel gate así
es daniela pues lamentable es este pacto
porque pues al final todos somos los
perjudicados muchísimas gracias a usted
este mes gracias continúa con nosotros